let's get right out to the i-team's
vanessa murphy she's live near sunset
and the 5 15 with the latest vanessa
yeah it was a close call for one family
as shots were fired pretty close to a
two-year-old child that child's father
tells me he tried to break up a fight
before he knew a gun was involved now
you can see the scene here police are
still investigating
they are looking for a shooter here's
video we shot earlier henderson police
say again they are looking for a shooter
after two people were shot after one
this afternoon and they went to a local
hospital on their own the father of the
child tells me he had just left costco
down the street and saw a fight between
at least three people happening near the
gas pumps here i asked him why he
decided to step in
just being a good person just trying to
get him to separate and then when i saw
like two people like you know like in
the car fighting one guy in the back
seat my wife's like look they're jumping
on him so i was just trying to pull him
apart
just trying to be a good guy
the child and her dad who you heard from
and her mom say they are okay shaken up
but relieved they are not hurt we do not
have the names of anyone involved
including the alleged shooter but
nathaniel wells who you heard from there
says two people involved including the
shooter were wearing wendy's uniforms
now you can see pretty close to the
scene the gas station is over here if we
turn this way you can see wendy's is
right next door that information about
the uniforms though not confirmed by
wendy's management or police again
police say they are looking for a
shooter after two people were shot here
in henderson reporting live vanessa
murphy 8 news now